[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record
we talk about whatever the first
shoot of the year it is it's the first
shoot of twenty-five
first
[Applause]
no more corona eminem dropped a surprise
album
eminem oh my god here we go here we go
right before christmas why do we have to
start the year this way we talk about
whatever we want
we talk about it except for eminem no
eminem we have a full eminent band a
really good album
okay so you're approved how come i
didn't hear it side b
i don't know y'all are losers i heard
the last one that came out
well then you haven't been paying
attention okay isn't eminem it has been
now
no how dare you aren't you a husband
oh i know yeah we are we all are this is
a room of them
his whole album is about how he's not a
husband and then he's still
got more places to go oh that's sad
where's he going higher than he's ever
been before the retirement center
it's just lyrics just reading the
[ __ ] lyrics she's not even here
anymore he thinks he's hit his limit
she's gone she'll come back later so
what'd you guys do during this break i
seemed like everyone had a lot of fun
what did you guys do
i stayed home my daddy liar
we stayed home we haven't seen anyone
since november at all not anyone
that sounds sad i haven't even gone to a
grocery store nothing no human
interaction
at all did you just have like food from
last month or two months ago
instacart beach it's a car you had it
delivered yes
you guys didn't even do like a road trip
to stay in the car youtube yeah rv that
[ __ ] that's what we've
done why they no longer see the world
it's terrible
i have cats i like to play with my cats
yeah what if they've coughed on your
groceries though that you're still
risking yourself
huh oh no to the groceries no i had
covet
i'm not risking them getting it yeah but
it doesn't last a bomb
no i no i had the but we had the
quarantine and then we had to miss
christmas because like my family was his
two weeks and then your two weeks
exactly
oh so it's a whole month hold on well i
mean yeah since
it'd be funny if you keep giving it back
to each other
that could still happen knock on wood
two weeks and then two weeks and then
two weeks and then two weeks so
your highlight was eminem dropping his
surprise thingy okay and i redecorated
my whole house
cool it looks so good thank you did your
couch come in it did
yes i got my couch i got new curtains i
got a new dining room we got new
lighting
i just went crazy i can't like sit still
so like if you're gonna tell me i'm
stuck at home for
a month and a half it's just
everything's gonna change at the house
yeah
that's what i mean because i think like
you were preoccupied so you didn't have
to go
anywhere so you had stuff to do at home
yeah going on a trip would just be a big
distraction when i hear a road trip i
always think that sounds tight and then
i'm on the road trip and i'm like this
[ __ ] sucks
i love i used to hate road trips but i
love them now did you grow up with road
trips yeah too many
i had that theory too i thought people
who grew up with it liked it
oh really yeah and then people that
weren't used to it they don't like it
because of how long it takes well listen
i had i was in a family with four kids
so when you're packed into a car you
[ __ ] don't like the road yeah
i could see that because i [ __ ] hated
road trips and so for all the jk stuff
like sometimes people would be like oh
why don't we drive there i mean why the
[ __ ] would you want to drive there if we
could fly there right
and then it sounds about park yeah and
then for one trip i don't know what it
was
but we were all in the car and we were
just talking you can hear different
conversations going on
i'm like oh man this is so nice and
that's when joe angie are like this is
why people like road trips you get the
bra
wait were you guys in an rv though i saw
pictures oh [ __ ] yeah we love the outfit
that's way different being in an rv is
different than being stuck in a car
that also wasn't even a road trip that
was stupid
wait what what an rv what was stupid we
didn't really rv
the rv oh yeah we didn't rv the artwork
do you mean you just used it for
transport
uh we used it as a house pretty much so
we yeah we flew into utah oh
so you know you usually get the rv so
you can sightsee along the way
we flew into utah and then got the rv
there and drove like 30 minutes into the
desert why didn't you just go to a motel
you [ __ ] way more fun
it was an experience i wanted to pretend
they went on a road trip but they didn't
want to drive the whole way
it was a mad max themed party that like
with our closest friends uh
yeah it was super rad your closest
friends
missed that her closest friends that
we've never met before
in the fitness space it was there thanks
so we're not in the fitness space either
you know you're not in the fitness space
we're very closest friends
you know you're not in the fitness look
at this whoa
you could be in the business
yeah so in this fitness space that they
were our closest friends there
so it was just like yeah um so yeah we
just parked the rv's in a big ass circle
in the middle of the desert and we just
[ __ ]
hung out and have conversations and just
[ __ ] what are those things those atv
thingies
they're like side-by-sides or like those
can-am things so they're just like
ripping through the desert it was pretty
fun sounds like diet burning man yeah oh
yeah yeah
burning man that's what it looks like it
did look like that yeah it's like a yeah
it was like a um
live-in like that dirt bike life so for
me
i was like like one of the only few
minorities there i was like is this what
white people do for fun in the dirt
and it made me go this is why you got to
buy dirt bikes and stuff because it's
[ __ ] rough you guys have like
steampunk wardrobes
yeah yeah because it was like mad max
post-apocalyptic theme
where do you even find that stuff amazon
baby she bought all my [ __ ] i don't know
yeah it was amazon amazon has literally
everything so it's just beautiful people
in the desert
wearing mad max [ __ ] yeah
i'm not giving a [ __ ] nothing's a
surprise anymore nothing's weird
and just like racing i know right that
is pretty weird that sounds pretty fun
though
and then we were so it was our last day
we were going to fly out our flight got
pushed back and then
somehow we found out he's in utah so
we're like what let's [ __ ] grab
breakfast and then we just hung out yeah
that was really cool that was just
random
yeah because i was um not even planning
on going to utah
but i wanted to do a snowboard trip so
i've been in like
seven states one country this whole time
i
only this whole trip like since the last
shoot
i've only been home one time to sleep
wow
like one night one night yeah because i
was gonna be in the east coast and we
were just gonna hit up all these
different slopes
oh wow and then what happened was we
decided to come back
on the 30th and then do vegas for new
year's on the 31st but we were so
tired and jet lagged we just fell asleep
at like 10 p.m
and then we drove up on the first to go
snowboarding and all that and we found
out that they were in utah too
so yeah that was really crazy meeting
you guys up there
having breakfast hanging out going on a
uh
there was this big lake that was frozen
full of duck [ __ ]
yeah and then me and bar were just
chasing the birds and then the birds
were just flying away and we
kept stomping on it trying to crack the
ice yeah oh what the [ __ ] because i was
trying to do the you know the thing in
the movies where like
like mark wahlberg is running away but
then the ground is cracking
so i wanted to get it to crack so i can
start running but
it was it wouldn't break it wouldn't
crack but it would make the cracking
sounds
so i was like get the [ __ ] out of there
and it wouldn't crack you know what was
crazy is you all posted pictures
and you on a frozen lake oh yeah ducks
and you were all
you're in different places oh i just
said duck because
i was throwing the thing but there were
no ducks were you in case you're trying
to break the ice and do the mark
wahlberg thing no way
oh no that was the second lake i saw
frozen tube
no it was really solid though i'm pretty
sure even if we tried to eat that is one
of the dumbest [ __ ] things i've ever
heard
but imagine imagine the [ __ ] story we
would have been telling you like this
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] was [ __ ]
jumping onto the lake fell through it
would have been epic
i felt i fell in a frozen lake um the
first one
in maine there was a big frozen lake
[ __ ] was it cold as [ __ ]
only my left leg yeah it was pretty
[ __ ] cold but
the rim of it so like where like it
meets the water meets the
like the shore or whatever right that
part it doesn't freeze up
but then the rest of the lake does so
you got to kind of figure out a way to
like get on the ice
and i was on thin ice and my left leg
just went boom
when it cracked it's so scary i saw a
friend
it feels like glass just breaking under
you were you like you could slip in
there and then it's hard you can't get
out because it's like
yeah never even thought of that oh [ __ ]
did see a frozen river and i was the
idiot that was like oh i want to see if
i could break it
but i was not on top of the actual like
it was just one foot and i was still on
the rock on the edge and i'm like oh
maybe i could break it
how do all of you have these thoughts
i'm like keeping the [ __ ] away from
there
steve and i are like we like to party in
a coffee shop by the fire
we're drinking booze we're like we're
having the best time you guys are the
parents we're the [ __ ] wild kids but
but you know what i am like hey bart go
try to do mark wahlberg
[ __ ] yeah he wants to watch bart do it
yeah i'll [ __ ] watch out the wizard
you are totally a parent
i started following like the most
redneck page in the world
and you know those pilot jack things oh
yeah of course it goes like this and it
like lifts the pallet
there's this guy he's riding it this way
so the two forks are behind him
and he has uh i think like six leaf
blowers
strapped to the back of it and they're
all on and he's [ __ ] going forward
like this i'm like that is
tight sick actually so if i do
reincarnate i hope i come back like in
the midwest or something so i could
be part of a family i mean you can just
do that now i do that [ __ ] now
dude but then like do you look at me and
like get off my rod
no they sounds like you're bringing the
midwest to europe it's so funny because
we did that [ __ ] we just stopped doing
it i don't have enough leaf blowers to
do
i mean like we did stupid [ __ ] like 15
years ago
but we just was appropriate i don't know
i just feel like we just now you're
saying you're just feeling just
responsible now
i just want to embrace who my brain is
and i've been trying to like
put up this fake i'm an adult but i'm
like i don't think i don't think
anyone ever thought
you just [ __ ] try to crack ice on a
on a pond and you think you're
responsible adult speaking of
responsible this off the record is
brought to you
by upstart and upstart is awesome
because it can help get your finances in
check which is
one of the biggest things if you're
trying to be responsible with your adult
life
you know that credit card that you're
afraid to look at and see what the
balance is if you've been avoiding your
debt
it's time to confront it and upstart can
help you face it and finally pay it off
last year showed us that you never know
what life is going to throw at you and
if you use
credit cards to pay for unexpected
expenses it can be
overwhelming to manage that debt
especially if you have a bunch of credit
cards you have to check all the balances
all the time
so you can take control with upstart so
you know exactly what to expect
and if you have multiple credit cards
know that tracking multiple balances due
dates and website logins can be
stressful upstart makes things simple
with one monthly payment in one place
i wish i had something like this when i
was in college because right when i
graduated i had about 40 grand
in debt with credit cards yeah and the
apr
on them were about like 16 17
so it was rough right and then what i
had to do was at the time i was getting
offers from different credit card
companies for zero apr meaning like
they're not gonna stack up
more on top of what you owe yeah and
then so i signed up for those and then i
had to
move the money into those but it was
crazy but like with upstart
you can do that all centralized into one
thing and i wish
i had this back then and upstart is the
fast
and easy way to get a personal loan to
pay off your debt all online
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
a simple fixed monthly payment
upstart finds smarter rates with trusted
partners because
they assess more than just your credit
score with a five minute online rate
check you can see your rate up front for
loans from 1 000 to
50 000 see that would have helped me
that's a lot you can get approved the
same day
and can receive funds as fast as one
business day
if debt is taking over your life it's
time to get a fresh
start with upstart so find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payments
today when you go to upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com off
the record
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you and loan amounts will
be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided on your loan application
go to upstart.com off the record and
start your 2021 off right
get debt free so how was colorado's that
would look pretty cool it looked
cold as hell it was cold as hell it was
like 16 degrees
in one day how many degrees 16 16. it
was cold just looking at your pictures
yeah it was really cold um what was your
question where'd you go how was it
how was it it was great how many people
went
she can't even answer yet when's your
birthday yeah november 29th
why you guys keep going to cold places
iceland colorado
well those are the only two but it
actually it worked out because then we
got to use all our iceland stuff in
colorado so
we have to buy new [ __ ] but but why did
we go so
the thing is so with casey's family
every single year we always
try to see each other for the holidays
and obviously this year was like
way more difficult but and so i was
proposing the fact that we can do a road
trip and meet in el paso and it could be
like oh they go from dallas to el paso
and then we go from l.a to el paso is
that the midpoint
about oh yeah and then so um
so then we were like they were gonna be
down to do it too but
so they had kovit already in the summer
or like early in the summer and so they
were like
we're not tripping about it like you
know we
we're pretty confident we're not gonna
get reinfected because it's like super
rare to get reinfected so for them they
were just like can we just fly and then
so the pandemic stuff it started calming
down by the time we ended up booking
this trip
so we're like well it might be okay like
if as long as we get tested and we just
stay really
safe then we should be fine so then we
ended up booking the trip and then the
closer we got to the trip like things
started getting crazier and i was like
[ __ ] it's a non-refundable trip
so we're like well let's just stick to
the plan we'll just get tested before we
go
and then we'll be really safe as we're
there so that's what we ended up doing
so we ended up meeting up in colorado
because they
really wanted to do a family vacation
type of thing denver
and yeah in denver and then so we spent
a week there and
since casey and i we still had some
extra time off we ended up going to
texas with them and we spent two more
weeks in texas what'd you guys do in
denver just explore the city um well
everything was closed it was like
it was like la it was like close close
closed um so
cool so you flew there for nothing you
flew there to be cold
pretty much the theme with colorado
though
is the nature is just driving there
for hours is to me that's that's that's
already rewarding so that's actually
what we ended up doing just drive
everywhere
we would drive to certain trails and we
went to like the
like red rock and like other like and we
went to the national park
the rock did you go to georgetown no
that's a cool little place did you see
my
mile high stadium no did y'all camp no
do you see snow
yes there it is did you see a deer
finally yes oh cool
what was his name i don't know bambi
baxter kolar
yeah that's all we did was just nature
[ __ ] but it was pretty hard like
difficult to just find anything else to
do what about back in texas was
everything
way different yeah so different texas is
like completely
practically open as like those two weeks
that we were there it was like as if
everything was open
um and i mean people were wearing masks
and stuff but it was nothing like l.a it
was really
weird because i'm like whoa it's like
normal life could you eat at a
restaurant inside that mm-hmm
oh i missed that so much i even got my
nails done
oh my god i miss getting where people
wear masks yeah everyone's wearing a
mask oh
so people are still wearing masks but
nothing's like completely closed does it
defeat the purpose
if you have a mask that's a confederate
fleck
because technically those would be like
anti-massacres right they're still
wearing a mask i think it works more
because the bars are in front of your
mouth
the virus can't get it just stops there
dude it's a little barrier
that's so stupid but i don't know but
yeah it was pretty cool that sounds
crazy
there's a lot of family time we actually
got bored at
at the end in texas no yeah casey and i
because we're like [ __ ] it's been
three weeks like for us i think 10 days
is our max and then
isaac didn't come with us so you miss
home [ __ ] yeah we missed home we missed
isaac we missed our cats and
yeah it was too long it was weird it
sounds awful to me but i'm glad you had
some fun some fun
that's the most sympathetic it was awful
no yeah
i was gone for a month and i finally
felt
what homesick was we also been locked up
the whole year pretty much
what do you mean like you know just like
you haven't really been he's like what
do you mean i haven't been locked up
like i've been on a flight every weekend
but you haven't been able to go to the
places you really wanted to go oh
right right right right yeah yeah cause
like yeah i was at home
alone for like two months straight yeah
yeah so it was getting it out of my
system
yeah yeah but i never really feel
homesick or like i miss
my bed or miss my things yeah this was
my first time like in
ages that i felt that what was the
moment that you felt that the most
uh probably like three days before
coming home i was like i'm ready to go
home because um
we were staying at my friend's friend's
house
and then uh they just had this massive
place and they were gone to tulum so we
had the house to ourselves
so we were just i was just sleeping
there and i'm like ah this is
i want to be in my bed and i'm ready to
work
like i'm i'm done having fun i had like
almost 30 days of non-stop
movement like straight up traveler style
right i can't do that yeah and at any
moment i can be like let's pull over and
just
look at this thing or like let's go and
snowboard tomorrow it was whatever i
wanted
and then at that point i was like okay i
want to get back
and like be productive yeah that's it
but it was good
i think it was really um what do you
call it like a reset
cathartic yes yeah really yeah what's
cathartic
it's like it's like nice that you did it
because it's
for your soul and [ __ ] yeah yeah getting
the feelings out yeah i stopped
um trying to schedule and structure
everything
i was like oh [ __ ] i can still manage to
do a lot without
having to plan ahead and it was nice
being with a friend who's so
um laughing i'm about to say i'm like so
you adopted darian's lifestyle yeah it's
a good balance because he's
way to the other side where every day is
a new day
and then i like a little bit of
structure and planning but then
um just kind of going with the flow and
seeing how he lives without stress
i was like i do this a lot to myself
so i was like yeah this is cool let's
just pull over to the side right now we
don't have to be anywhere
darian's the most carefree person in the
world that i don't think
he sees any like rules or
categories or something i think we once
we drove through a starbucks
and then i ordered what i wanted to
order and you'll go would you like to
have sir and goes
i'll get a pizza and then they're like
oh we don't serve pizza here and he was
like you don't
oh okay i'll get a hamburger so i think
he's just so free his
imagination is a hundred percent at all
the time he was customizing [ __ ]
at a subway it was so funny so you want
to just look at the menu
because they show you what they offer
maybe just read the sign into starbucks
yeah
but he knew but i think that's just how
his brain works it's just he's just so
free that there's no like oh wait they
don't have pizza at starbucks
dude i hope i do some dumb [ __ ] and you
guys are like this is just how it's free
it's so creative it's free spirited yeah
you know it's funny it's cause like
i'm so used to thinking ahead and being
like all right we gotta get tickets we
gotta do this and this
because there's a time when it does
backfire right because he'll plan a trip
and then find out that the slopes are
closed and it's like we did all this
[ __ ]
but it does backfire when you over plan
and then you go oh but it's like raining
and then you got to get refunds and then
now you booked all this [ __ ] and you got
to get your money back
isn't he the guy who didn't pack water
on a backpacking trip yep and
he was too stubborn to say i need water
no and a
anna and a [ __ ] uh sleeping bag so he
he didn't he pulled an
all-nighter next to the fire and he
didn't sleep he's just so free-spirited
sleeping bags are for [ __ ] everyone
giving your sweaters right now
[Laughter]
it was pretty funny
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you